hey leute ich bin im urlaub und erhole
mich war so ein bisschen können wir mal
eine auszeit auch beim rasieren und wenn
man da so ein bisschen zeit hat man
unternimmt nicht bei so einem wetter
hier so ein bisschen drüber
da kommt man ans nachdenken und überlegt
so das ein oder andere und eine idee war
haye eigentlich muss es so einen
richtigen kick zum tag geben und welcher
tag könnte das sein und dann habe ich
den kollegen telefoniert und haben
überlegt der samstag ist für eine
talkshow genau das richtige also dann
haben wir jetzt entschieden der samstag
unter der kommende samstag wird premiere
sein für clixoom als samstags talkshow
da beginnen wir dann immer mit dem
ersten video das wir jetzt auch talk
nennen wobei eine antwort so sage ich
immer noch interview weil die haben in
köln aufgezeichnet die nennwert org weil
es ist ja mehr im topf man lehnt sich
zurück es ist keine frage antwort spiel
sondern eher ein gespräch das sag ich ja
schon immer und warum habe ich
eigentlich interview genannt also wir
starten am samstag mit dem talk mit
einem der führenden wie locker in
deutschland und ich kann nur versprechen
es ist ein sensationelles interview weil
al ahli natürlich sensationell ist und
eine menge zu erzählen hat so also seid
gespannt auf den samstag und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran